in this lecture we discussed the
simplest non-trivial stochastic process
the Bernoulli process time is divided
into slots at each slot we have an
independent trial such as a coin flip
and each trial results in heads or tails
or in different language each trial may
or may not result in an arrival or a
success
pretty much everything we will do will
be a simple application of skills that
we already have for example we already
know that the number of arrivals in n
time slots is described by the binomial
PMF we will then discuss some
consequences of the independence of the
different trials basically the process
has no memory whatever happens in the
future is not affected by whatever
happened in the past by exploiting this
property we will find the distribution
of the time of the first arrival and
more generally of the time of the caithe
arrival we will also find the
distribution of the time between
consecutive arrivals next we will take
two independent Bernoulli processes
let's say arrivals of men and arrivals
of women and merge them to get an
overall arrival process we will see that
the merged process is also a Bernoulli
process we will also look at the reverse
operation namely splitting a Bernoulli
process into two separate processes
finally we will look at a particular
asymptotic regime in which we have a
large number of time slots but a very
small probability of an arrival during
each time slot we will carry out some
algebraic manipulations and we will see
that the binomial PMF for the number of
arrivals can be well approximated by the
so-called Poisson PMF